this is Startalk i'm here from Startalk
radio with Cady Coleman thanks for
taking time to chat with us today so our
fans actually sent in some questions and
I could ask them okay okay great thanks
so I'm the first question what sort of
day-to-day roles do astronauts have in
the preparation and planning of current
human spaceflight operations we have a
little finger in every pie that is
involved
and so that means for the space station
you know we've got people who are you
know working on training and trying to
make sure that astronauts are being
trained in a way that astronauts think
they should be training we're not in
charge of training but we've got no and
I in there and for example my job in
supply ships making sure that the people
on or the space station understand
what's going on on the ground and that
the people on the ground you know it's
SpaceX and Orbital Sciences and that our
friends in Japan that they understand
what life is like for the crew when
they're trying to grab that school bus
sized thing so we're always involved i
would say in every aspect of human space
flight and that includes tomorrow's
flight of
I first applied where we have had
astronaut stuffs assigned to Orion
helping engineers when they're trying to
decide you know is this necessary can we
get rid of this you know which things
can we which things are really necessary
those are our astronaut representatives
and they bring those questions back to
the estrin office and we talked about
and we talked about the pros and cons
what's too important to give up and so
we're involved in the whole the whole
deal truly interactive it's absolutely
never ends right thank you okay our next
question what do you think is the
biggest hurdle toward establishing a
permanent human presence in space money
well seriously you know it really the
things that we're doing in order to do
them safely it's really expensive and we
also have a fairly risk-averse society
right now where people want to see
success after success when things like
this or you're really tackle
I mean if you are totally successful all
the time it's probably not the unknown
we are tackling the unknown and the
thing and we're making sure that we
basically have a safe path to the moon
asteroids and Mars in a vehicle that
people can voyage out into the solar
system live other places eventually
it'll happen
space is never one
the basis
okay what was the most unusual
experiment sent up to the ISS to be done
in microgravity actually can I answer a
question number two again absolutely so
you know I just being kind of flip than
I said money
and it's true but it's actually more
practical of that too it's technology
I'd like to say we're ready to go to
Mars
we have steps that we need to take and
we are taking now you know we need
propulsion that will get us there in a
result mountain we need life support
systems that are going to be able to
recycle the air we can't bring it all
with us and the water and our supplies
so we need those things and working on
them right now testing solar array
panels to understand how to have more
energy for solar electric power there's
all sorts of all sorts of things that we
need the technology for researching
those things eventually we'll have them
and we'll be ready to go thank you so
much a most unusual experiment that you
know of sent up to the ISS to be done in
microgravity I guess I think of the
experiments that we do ourselves of
there as the ones that might be
considered the most unusual and that is
you know sometimes just with your food
you know the games that we play the
games that were you make up as we spend
time up there and enjoy each other's
company and those things all have
implications for processing here on the
ground for understanding what we can't
really do in space in
and for understanding some physics that
are a little bit unexpected so I think
that everything can be an experiment and
that's why it's pretty delightful to get
there human food example we've seen the
mms flying around we've seen the gloves
of liquid anything come to mind well the
most deadly example is barbecue sauce I
mean most in your friend is you know
you're very carefully you know having
your BBQ beef and and then you know just
with that last spoonful you lose your
focus and a little bit of a lose your
concentration and and sort of flip that
spoon in that little glob of barbecue
sauce is like a homing pigeon and it
goes straight for your crewmates brand
new shirt of which they only have six up
it happens you're on earth too but not
quite the same way yeah um okay what
immediate and long-term benefits do you
expect from manufacturing in space we
know 3d printer just went up there and
any thoughts about that
I like to think about benchmark examples
things that we can't make here on the
ground in the field of some looking at
how to Anthony form different crystals
with different mixtures we're on the
ground there's a sedimentation process
that really dominates and so we can't
really see what are the limits or what
are the heights of semiconductor
crystals that we can achieve the same
for any kind of crystal sort of
metal alloys what do we look around and
find that it's made of metal what does
well did for us most everything
is able to be sort of sustainable
you know in equipment that's used a lot
metal is
being able to have stronger lighter
metals are is important for a lot of
applications down here on earth and also
going to space less wait to get to orbit
very good thank you okay um Scott Kelly
is going to be undergoing a 12-month
space mission I know you're up there for
six does he have to train differently
for that duration and are there concerns
beyond those we have four astronauts
currently up in space for shorter
durations part of the reason to send a
black spot is that we want him we want
someone to go for a year we want to
understand what are those differences
we've been noticing some risks to being
up there and we need to understand you
know are they something that just
happens we
internal
and so is that something that happens
right when you get up there and it stays
constant
this is something that gets worse and
worse and worse over a long duration
right now our data is limited to between
three and six
really long enough to be able to use as
our basis for sending people further so
on purpose we're sending Scott a little
bit
to understand what happens to
and I think that it involved psychology
as well
for training right I think it's
important to set your expectations
to really realize ahead of time that you
you know up there for a while and have
limited kinds of communication and how
are you going to that
ok and I'm going to end up with this
question ok if you were offered a
one-year mission would you go and would
you be up for Mars mission I would go
for a one-year mission in a moment I
mean if Scott got sick tomorrow I would
be in his shoes did so many of us would
you know we spend a lot of time getting
ready making sure we know all the things
that we need to know to be resources up
there on that space station and once you
have all those tools I think the the
passion that we have for moving the
marker forward for learning more up
there all of us would like to be that
person
help learn those things and I'd love to
live there and I figure earth will still
be here when I'm careful about Mars and
Mars I would do would you it's probably
easier for me to say that knowing
probably it's going to be folks from the
younger generation that are going to be
the ones to go so it might be a little
easier
but I go well this goes out to all the
friends and fans of Startalk radio I
love it that there's a whole group of
people listening at the same time and
they're all passionate about what we see
when we look up so keep looking up